je te demande d'excusés aux joueurs trop
sur audrey doubt un jeu absolument pas
français a apparemment donc on va le
mettre en anglais droite bac et
maintenat gp jouer et ça serait voilà
partis alors c'est parti
watt et ses bienfaits comme jeu sans dec
par contre le vibreur il est vraiment
violent il est très très bien je sais
que vous êtes tous tombés dans le piège
et vous avez tous vos portables
ça doit être là non ouais
e bonjour je suis sur un tapis ira
incoming au d'accord donc stephen boggs
ok c'est un iris von je sais ce que ça
existe
quelqu'un connait et des cas donc ça
c'est la particularité de la mise à jour
de lier respawn ce qu'on voit des
fantômes dans l'appareil photo
c'est super alors c'est parti avec ce
petit téléphone un discours peu jeu
d'accord donc l'alba coup et ont paniqué
je suppose un temps bon tu vois une
femme plutôt bizarre nos iphone tu te
chie dessus
donc là je les ramasse et là donc on va
aller par là
bonjour a donc ça c'est coucou tu auras
une photo avec moi joli fantôme vient de
l'ensemble alors c'est par où donc j en
vois juste dix millions de fois mieux
comme ça là y'a une porte on va pouvoir
s'en aller allez je m'en fais pop fin du
jeu merci du monde c'est manu watts
tandis qu'elle me veut elle là je me
sent le piège là tu veux quoi tu veux un
gain des frites ah ah j'ai mal à la tête
tu étais trop moche bon j'ai déjà patron
lance maurice et web
donc j'ai carrément devoir regarder dans
mon téléphone qua non je dois je regarde
bon apparemment n'a pas trop le choix
comment vous dire que si on ne va pas là
va nulle part alors oui on voit on voit
vraiment rien tant qu'on n'est pas dans
le téléphone et oui je me chie dessus
oui pour ceux qui se demandent oui ça
fait très peur
we would you luce ayaba volant iris et
matt est connu dans le jeu mais
uniquement dangereux par contre ça faut
le préciser
elle commence à avoir très peur
maintenant je vois absolument rien je
vois là je sais pas où je vais où
vais-je s'il vous plaît aidez moi
indiquez moi le chemin on passe dans les
cheveux ah non oh mais ça va pas bien
mais ça va pas bien de faire ça tu veux
mais tu n'es qu'un territoire et à
vapeur ça va pas du tout [ __ ] même pas
passé je me casse je m'en vais avec mon
téléphone je vais faire tout le demande
c'est quoi et on peut activer l'option
je me réveille dès mon rêve
non mais pas stoppée au soleil ah bon
alors on va se balader comme ça donc là
bas je crois qu'il ya rien par contre
j'adore ne pas trouver du tout mon
chemin à abong par roussey mais castrés
mais arrête bordel ça fait du tout ça
pas du tout on va couper du bambou what
what donc cette femme a fumé une
quantité astronomique de de n'importe
quelle drogue pour en arriver là on est
tous d'accord je m'en vais vers le
phénix au volant tout blanc
allez vas-y ouais c'est un petit fils
devant comme ça au bout il sait que
c'est la haye et donc je n'y vois rien
où vais-je que se passe-t-il là-bas
saint jacques fait peur aux singes what
the fuck final je ne comprends pas tout
ah bon je marche je marche tout devient
blanc vais je m'en sortir que je propose
les chips j'ai quelqu'un de 13 à la
boîte de fac d ate est ce qu'on vient
juste de revenir à la vie pour
recommencer le jeu du pack elle encore
là l'autre a tu n'es plus là on peut pas
aller par là non bon alors on peut aller
à lons et bonjour mais c'est la même
chose que tout à l'heure en fait elle a
des doigts dégueulasse cette femme à mon
dieu mais qu'apparemment on la voit là
en train de boîtes venant faire un
escrimeur qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
dans ce jeu en fait sauf peut-être juste
à prendre en photo à rien de se passer
là il ya une espèce de bruit de l'image
on a pu passer dans le trou du mur
plantations bah voilà et ben voilà à
oisy le ring macbook ou cette porte
où es-tu femmes de l'ombre mon trottoir
ne m'enferme pas non c'est quoi ce
délire là mais arrêtez les chauves
souris à elle entre dans le délire je ne
veux pas de fou mais arrête et je
continue à jouer
tiens pas fin j'étais pris en photo à
sata fortement touchés non ici on se
fait carrément chier il n'y a pas
d'ambiance dans cette armoire et louis
cette [ __ ] de chauves-souris je vais
la défoncer mais c'est mais arrête mais
c'est un insecte il est immense ges mois
il est où j'ai acheté du bim paf
regardez regardez moi ou smooth il vient
de disparaître suite
aux améliorations technologiques les
moustiques ont développé leurs super
pouvoirs de disparaître et maintenant
j'ouvre escrimeurs du coup à une porte
je me suis enfermé dans le placard
pendant deux minutes avec un [ __ ] de
moustiques pour finalement avoir pris la
mauvaise direction
voilà c'est ça qui vient de se passer un
pour ceux qui se demanderaient la fois
qu'ils habitent
ok alors photo ma veste a pour fêter ça
on s'en va pourquoi cette femme en est
arrivé là
et si j'enlève ça on voit on voit que
dalle on est d'accord on voit que dalle
alors bien évidemment bien gentiment
nous allons devoir aller à l'état joue
alors à droite là avoue penser que
j'allais pas voir cette partie que
j'aurai finalement préféré ne pas voir
et je cours autant en emporte le vent
le lissage boîte je vais pouvoir rentrer
au nom au non non attendez ce nounours
s'est pendu qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pourquoi tu t'es pendu regarde je te
prends en photo je te reprends je te
reproche tout reproche parfois je t'en
prie aime papa baba tempest appellerait
ça va pas la caméra s'est arrêtée au
moment où je les ai vus allez un
shooting photo à l'effet doute le
meilleur profil allez allez allez le
meilleur g10 le meilleur mais elle va
carrément que tu es là elle va carrément
me marchez queue de cheval
bonjour
you were not my friend quiétude fais pas
mon ami je sais pas mais tu dois dégager
pourquoi tu te moques arrête arrête de
te moquer mais si on peut pas parler
avec toi si je suis pas ton fresnes
si je suis pas ton ami alors alors
qu'est-ce que je suis un fantôme un ba
ouai ok je te suis je te suis arrête
arrête aux bâtards et c'est la mort qui
va te toucher ma petit alors vous parlez
je pose et elle va se faire décapiter la
tête et elle va se faire défoncer la
baie non mais là c'est trop d'émotions
la what's going on a jeté retrouver mon
ami que tu fais là tu es puni
tu as oublié ton bonnet d'âne mais moi
je ne veux pas te rejoindre
ok je te vois un fait gaffe fais gaffe à
es16 photo tu vois tu la fais ton plus
beau profil
et là elle se réveilla pour rejoindre
l'ange céleste de nouveau bond du cac
juste vous aura plus de 300 nouvelles
très bientôt
donnez moi du tag en émoi du tac je veux
vivre les voilà il va mourir à tout ce
temps et nous voilà prêts comme ça non
plus